[Music]
cell phone as your daily planner or your
gaming device or a social outlet but do
someone in an abusive relationship it's
a Lifeline it got so mad and it started
choking me and my son woke up and he was
crying and that did not stop him from
keep keep going I would have made me
even more mad yeah a domestic Survivor
remembers that one night particularly
well I eventually um managed to you know
run out the house without shoes and I
run to the neighbor to ask for a phone
so I can call the cops because he had
took all the phones from me Joanne has a
complicated relationship with phones she
said it was a way for her ex to monitor
her it was a tool of control for years A
lot of people are depending financially
from their abusers until she finally
separated from from her family plan and
got her own phone if you've ever tried
to change your cell phone yeah Royce I
found it thank you I I found it took a
minute but I found it right after this
number or your cell phone plan you know
how incredibly challenging it can be
even without an abusive relationship but
adding domestic violence and it gets
exponentially harder that though is
about to
change the Federal Communications
Commission is set to boat Wednesday on
Landmark new guidelines that will force
cell phone providers to be more
responsive to victims of domestic
violence part of the
responsibility so my cell phone bill is
going to go up $6 a month because women
don't know how to pick good men yeah
maybe your responsibility was to make
sure dinner wasn't cold yeah you we all
have responsibilities in this yeah what
does it have to do with Sprint mhm will
mask calls to domestic violence hotlines
and shelters from cell phone bills make
it easier for victims to separate from
their family plans and provide new
lowcost phones for men and women who
need to escape a dangerous situation so
that way when you call like a domestic
violence shelter it'll like in the phone
it'll say totally not a domestic
violence shelter right right right right
right it'll say Pizza Hut you know what
would be funny though is if we really
did say Pizza Hut and then he beats her
because he's like are you ordering Pizza
Hut you know I like Domino's [__] you
know I like their boneless wings beat
the [__] out of her God damn
it
living through really Unthinkable
circumstances and suffering quietly with
domestic abuse it is hard to pick up
that phone and call someone and it's
doubly hard if you know that there's
going to be a record of it that you're
abuser will see Jessica Rosen Rell the
first woman to ever lead the FCC has
been shaping the new regul oh good a
woman's leading the FCC that's
cool relations with input from Advocates
including those the National Domestic
Violence Hotline are you safe to talk
right now which
makes I'm sorry but I could just
thinking with all how bad the
government's
run you call you call the National
Domestic
hotline and you get
this yes please stand by your caller 400
and 56 your estimated weit time is 27
hours
a lot of other women are bad at picking
potential Partners so your time may be
more than
expected your expected hold time is 4
hours 37
minutes help help we're sorry you're
having
trouble please hold and soon we'll
dispatch a police officer to come and
shoot
you and your dog for no
reason oh oh God poor poor woman's dead
already yeah yeah she's yes this is
Jamal I am with the United States
government my husband just smashed a
face over my head and he's beating me
with a hammer I am very sorry you are
having this problem I know if I was
getting hit with hammer I would not be
having a good day let me please look
into first may I get your uh full
address and is this phone number
associated with your can I speak to her
supervisor okay but when we are finished
here may you please stay on the line for
a brief survey to tell them how well I
did okay yeah
fine write your address on V and send
picture from be on way oh
[__] sorry this is really [__] up
women are getting guys seriously stop
hitting people stop hitting women
cut it out it makes for hilarious
bits domestic violence is pretty funny
oh [__] for like 50% of the people
yeah 90,000 contacts each month more
than a million each year and most of
those victims reach out via cell phone
know I think about when I worked in a
local shelter yeah that's how most
people reach out coming in with
kids who has a landline who's getting
beat with a land line what the
[__] I'm going to
start I swear to God look if there's one
thing right now I'm gonna warn you I I I
get very violent when women start crying
oh [__] I cannot control it oh
[__] I know like my AA is not a good one
a woman coming into the shelter with her
children and the cell phone being the
vehicle that she would use to look for a
job to call the local Clinic to be able
to communicate with her kids school we
have to be able to have the ability for
her to do that safely and privately to
protect not but before that can we have
like pick better husband
hotline maybe you know mhm yeah make
better decisions hotline and you know
cuz here's the problem is look look men
that be women obviously are [__]
terrible I I understand that no one's on
the other oh why you got to come at me
on the air nobody nobody's on the other
side of that except
Virgie but that being said there's a lot
of these people that I've known in per
my personal life right where a lot of
these people date these I can fix them
guys you know who already there's red
flags everywhere to begin with but they
kind of like that he's a dick they kind
of like that he's dangerous of course
and they like the validation they like
when he punches a hole in a drywall CU
it makes them feel like right he loves
me so much he's willing to kill he loves
me so much he's willing to kill me yeah
that's that's what we want in life that
sounds great if you want that that means
Israel really loves Palestinians date
Marilyn
Manson